Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so awesome news
the rock finally confirmed that he's going
do black Adam it will be two movies I'll explain
what's going on and why he is going to help
save the DC universe along with the flash.
He had this big meeting at DC comics that
he was teasing that the producers on the project
right now just hyping things up saying how
they are going to bring fun to the DC universe.
That's in addition to what's going on with
Justice league the flash movie all coming,
so I'll explain all that.
There's a long history of shazam in the comics
it's a little confusing, so I'll give a brief
introduction on the character too, but there's
a new round of the flash ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enters be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so we gotta
talk about how the rock and the flash are
going to save the DCEU I feel like Batman
will too but he's more of a known quantity.
I feel like it's a lot easier for characters
you're not totally familiar with to surprise
you and that's really where the rock comes
in and everyone has just been saying how awesome
the flash is so I'll explain all this number
five what is going on with the shazam movie.
So originally it was going to be a shazam
movie background 2014 the rock was brought
on.
He was like all hell yeah you know me to bring
it.
It's can be awesome, to kick so much as.
So everything was good.
But that was during the original DCEU release
schedule since then that schedules change
quite a bit.
So what they're doing now is there going to
do two movies set in the shazam group of characters
in one of them will just be a total black
Adam movie, so the rock is getting his own
spinoff movie and the other movie will presumably
just focus more on the Billy Batson character
with black Adam in it.
So number four why they do in this like why
they splitting into two movies but this is
a really good idea.
I think just because there are so many shazam
characters they're all DC characters.
But the shazam family is so big and so complicated
in the Backstory is so crazy that I think
they just need some more time to flesh that
out and you get more movies to get more time
to develop the characters it winds up sidestepping
that problem where you try to stuff too many
characters into a movie.
So they haven't officially announced a release
date.
But originally that shazam movie was set to
come April 5, 2019.
They might just fast-track the black Adam
movie because they haven't cast the Billy
Batson character yet but they do have the
rock in the DC universe definitely needs the
rock right now way more than the rock needs
the DC universe.
This is where we get to the idea of the rock
saving the DCEU.
Not single-handedly because there's like a
couple really big things that are happening
in the next couple years that I think will
just completely turn people around that are
really big fans of what's going on right now.
So like the wonder woman movie Justice league
all big steps in the right direction.
I think they'll be great but someone like
the rock who just loses charisma and as a
PR machine is just so good at getting people
into theaters think about what he did for
the fast and furious franchise those were
entertaining movies, but when he came on board
with that fifth one.
That's when it really started to go crazy.
That is a multibillion-dollar franchise.
And even though I think the DC movies are
way way better than the fast and furious movies,
but the rock is just one of those people who
is just so great at playing that alpha male
character and that is so much what black Adam
is so if you're not familiar with his back
story he was the original shazam character
who turned evil then much much later the wizard
shazam created a new one and that became Billy
Batson and he was the good one, they fought
each other they became mortal enemies.
But if you're little confused or you haven't
read comics in a while are you still think
that the characters called Captain Marvel
what happened is is back in 2012 DC officially
stopped using the Captain Marvel name because
Billy Batson Captain Marvel was what the character
was originally called when he started at Fawcett
comics before DC bought the brand.
So this is great story about the history of
that character.
There's the Marvel family already, it sounds
like a big legal nightmare.
So number three what happened way back in
the early 1950s is is that DC pressured Fawcett
comics to stop using the Captain Marvel character
because he was a ripoff of Superman way later
DC bought those characters and started using
them, but in that time Marvel created their
own Captain Marvel character and trademarked
it.
So Marvel owns the trademark even though faucet
comics created Captain Marvel before them
because of that weird distinction DC continue
to use the Captain Marvel name all the way
up until near 2012, when they officially just
started calling Billy Batson shazam because
most people behind the scenes just felt like
you looked at him and you thought that he
was shazam anyway, but technically it's the
wizard shazam in the Marvel family.
So for all those that are wondering.
That is why the character is no longer called
Captain Marvel is a trademark issue DC just
doesn't want to get into some long legal battle
with Marvel comics, but number two you know
what they might do for the story of the movie
is adapted version of the new 52 origin story,
which is a little bit simpler and it explains
how you get the family.
But they might just cut out the family.
They might just use the Billy Batson character
during that origin story you learn how the
black Adam character is very similar to Billy
Batson.
They both grew up in extreme tragedy black
Adam escaped slavery Billy Batson lost his
parents.
He's been on his own with these foster children
for a while you learn how black Adam wasn't
able to move past that childhood trauma worrying
black Adam cannot 6U here is my grievous mistake
one for which today when Lily ago I chose
him to be this world's protect he was entrusted
with great but it's hard for the same seven
that all I was forced star is for the next
5000 years making sure I would not chose a
new why you course I've been watching for
some time.
Billy and now the stone with the wisdom, strength,
stamina power and speed you, and so when he
became all-powerful, he just became this crazy
dictator trying to save people sort of like
crushing them under the burden of his freedom.
So he thinks of himself as a hero even though
he's so extreme that he is definitely the
antagonist Billy Batson on the other hand,
learns to adjust learns to be a hero and actually
defeats black Adam by tricking him not using
force just knowing that black Adam is such
a bad ass.
There's no way he could ever be to minified
because black Adam is about 5000 years old.
He tricks him into turning his powers off
and he basically turns to dust so that's his
end in the new 52 obviously the movies are
going to kill them off.
That way, so fast, but it's a relatively linear
story word you learn about the seven deadly
sins like all the Backstory behind the Marvel
family how their powers work.
So shazam is actually an acronym for all the
different gods whose powers they get, and
they basically can call upon one power at
a time.
So there stamina swiftness, strength, wisdom,
power, encourage that's black out of power,
so they can call upon those at any given time,
which is how they're able to fight Superman,
but because their powers come from magic Superman
is very weak against them.
So usually you defeat black Adam by tricking
him somehow it does because if you were to
try to go pound for pound with them.
You look at the rock here he would be chew
into a pile of Jell-O imagine the rock punching
Henry cavill as Superman with lightning fists
it be so crazy which is why you know number
one I feel like wonder woman in Superman would
be great cameos in the shazam black Adam movie,
just because wonder woman comes from a very
mystical place.
Superman is one of the few characters that's
as powerful and is this big influence on Billy
Batson because you have to remember that even
though he becomes this adult when he activates
his powers he still like an 11-year-old kid.
So, what a coincidence that the same week
the rock is meeting at DC to sort of figure
his movie out is also hanging out with Henry
cavil.
They also share the same management company.
So there's all the stuff.
The just pointing towards collaboration coming
up so it's gonna be a lot of fun and when
the rock posted this that's basically what
he was saying this is one of the reasons why
he's going to save the DCEU because he can
be hardcore, but a lot of fun at the same
time so that is where the flash also comes
into.
So I feel like the aesthetic of the DCEU is
totally on point.
They did an amazing job with the look and
feel.
But some of the really fun characters just
aren't there yet like wonder woman was barely
in Batman be Superman.
We haven't seen Justice league yet so haven't
really got a lot of the flash it.
So people like Aquaman to like all these characters
that are gonna be so much fun just haven't
quite arrived yet, which is why were all waiting
for the Justice league trailer.
So, I know everybody still wondering when
that's gonna come this going to be some new
wonder woman, really soon because that movie
is coming out in June the probably drops a
new Justice league relatively soon, but I'm
not expecting the Super Bowl trailer there
might be some teaser around the Super Bowl.
But I be very, very surprised, so let me know
what you want them to do with black Adam in
the Justice league franchise.
I feel like they'll slowly have to introduce
him in one of the Justice league movies.
They were to shot the first one.
So if you like the second movie is actually
a really good target for that but he just
get to be such an awesome jolt of energy into
the DCEU in the same way the flash is for
Justice league.
I love the way that all the Justice league
actors are saying their favorite character
is the flash in the Justice league movie.
So I think everybody's can be really happy
with the way it all goes down let me know
in the comments though what kind of DC movie
videos you guys want me to do or even for
the TV stuff to the be a lot of flash TV stuff
happening because it's coming back next week
but later today about some new Logan movie
posting I'll be talking about the X 23 character
the future of Wolverine inside the Fox universe,
so it's going to be a lot of fun.
While you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for the flash trailer for next
week's episode and you can click here to rewatch
the injustice trailer.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!